have you boys ever had soju yeah yeah
it's good okay
why are you asking me like you know i
have no no no because of course i know
you had soju
okay so like i can't stand pure soju
but for some reason flavored soju is
just like
sorry
the pure one is like thirty i don't
drink the pure water the flavored ones
is it like twenty percent and like
tastes like hand sanitizer [ __ ] oh
it's gross gross okay
soju is the only like kind of i agree
with that i can do that
shots that goes well with beer i don't
know
why it actually does it actually does
dude it actually does say this
and then because you think of mixing
anything with beer right
and it sounds awful soju goes [ __ ]
amazing with beer especially flavored
soju
pour a beer and then drop the little
little shot in yeah
if you want a great but awful night
afterwards because again that's like
awful hangover it will [ __ ] you up i
don't know if our editor will include
this because he's the editor but there's
one
after the night where we bought like we
bought we bought
so for a party in the uk we did because
we were going to japan so we wanted to
do one last big party with all our
friends to celebrate and
our editor came from australia we're
calling you out now and uh
we had i went to new malden in london
which is the korean uh
area of london and i went to the korean
like supermarket
and i went and bought like three crates
of 20
of these bottles yeah yeah because there
was about how many of us was like 20.
it was more than three quarters there's
four crates four crates and they're all
you know
so we had 80 bottles of soju and they're
all like
750 milliliters each time yeah and um
when i bought it as well they were like
you know how strong this is right
and i'm like yeah yeah it's all good but
it's
so before before before conor was buying
them he was like how many crates should
we buy
and the because he was posting this in
the group party chat and everyone's just
like
hey more crates whatever right so he
rocks up with four crates of soju
and we all look at this being like this
is this we've we've completely
overestimated 80 quid i've ever spent in
my life
we've completely overestimated this and
so what happens is uh
one of us brought you know one of those
like beard and empty beer dispensers
yeah where you can fill up with beer
yeah so we we just filled up this beer
dispenser with pure surgery
right so this entire party uh instead of
like having pints of beer we would
literally like
just go to go to this soju go to this go
to the soju
dispenser get a glass and just pour like
ourselves off
a full glass of salt
we drank like nearly all the crates in
the first place so
yeah on the first night we went through
three and a half crates of soju
between like about 25 of us so we had
bunk beds in this place so naturally
fine
sick no no no no no actually no one
threw up i think actually
so so miracle so i'm sleeping in a bunk
bed with our editor
and he's above not inside same bed but i
wish that i'm kidding
so i'm sitting in the same bunk bed he's
above me and i wake up at like 6am
because obviously sometimes you know
after you drank you wake up a little bit
yeah yeah and i see him on the floor
like like this like i'm i'm sitting on
the bottom buck and i'm like
just like this at like 6 a.m and i'm
like
you okay he's like it hurts it hurts so
much
and i'm like what's wrong he's like i'm
so hungover and it hurts so much and i'm
like
understandable i'm going back to bed
bye-bye i'm going back to bed oh my god
he was he was out of operation the whole
day was so funny
he's a great editor though thank you
estonians man oh that was a good party
so chris when are you going to come to
one of a party in the uk with us we'll
make sure you
whatever it is fantastic
in the uk i i got really drunk and early
hijacked a boat with my estonian friend
in london
wait wait wait wait you can't just say
that
i can't go into detail